[Music]
so we so far we heard the results we had
with l3 at lab and now I will continue
and explain our plans for the future
namely our plans at LHC and first what
is LHC so here at CERN this is the Sun
complex showing the left wing and also
these pre injector systems here and the
plan is to use the lab tunnel insert a
new is some new magnets and new beam and
use this for PP collisions at 16 TeV and
this is called the Large Hadron Collider
or LHC now why are we actually
interested to go to LHC with the l3
detector and of course as you know so
far the standard model is actually doing
very well and in fact the tests we are
doing at the moment with l3 show for
instance that there are three families
and also the tests show that there's
your couplings are in agreement with the
standard model to a very high precision
clearly there are two missing points and
the first is the top quark and the
second is the Higgs boson the top quark
presently we know should be larger than
something like 90 GeV and I think
everybody agrees on most people agree
that the top should exist and if it's
below 150 GeV it will be found very soon
hopefully at Fermilab if it's heavier
than hundred 50 probably it will first
be found at LHC or as SSC now the next
part is actually somewhat more
interesting namely it's the Higgs boson
and this is the Higgs mechanism is
responsible to generate masses for WS
and Z's and we hope with l3 at the time
when LHC comes up that we will be able
to extraor its masses again up to
something like 90 GeV
so therefore the interest is to explore
masses beyond this 90 GeV range and of
course you can think now for instance
the Higgs mechanism in the standard
model is not correct for instance there
could be somewhat more complicated Higgs
mechanism so in other words you
have more than just one Higgs tablet
which is for instance predicted by
supersymmetry and then you should also
find many more new supersymmetric
particles or there is no Higgs mechanism
at all and then current theories predict
there should be other types of particles
around in the mass range above hundred
GeV or maybe it's the Higgs mechanism at
core is correct and clearly then we also
will look for some new types of
interactions so new types of vector
bosons e Prime and W prime so in any
case I think the solution to the major
problems and questions we have in the
standard model at the moment lie in this
range about one TeV and therefore they
are accessible at LHC which has a center
of mass energy of sixteen TeV now for us
clearly the most important question is
the experimental task the experimental
challenge and this can best be seen here
in this diagram where we see the
cross-section in proton proton collision
as function of the center of mass energy
and for it in C we have the cern
collider Fermilab LHC and SSC so the
first observation is that indeed the
interesting processes like Higgs
production Z prime production have cross
sections which are extremely small only
about 1 Pico bar so that means we have
to go to colliders which have an
extremely large luminosity but on the
other hand you see also that the real
background namely the total
cross-section is something like ten
orders of magnitudes larger so if you
have a high luminosity machine you have
a huge amount of background produced all
the time so therefore we need to build
detectors which are able to cope with
this kind of background to in to extract
signals let's say one event out of 10 to
the 10 background events and this is
really the experimental challenge and so
what we are planning then is the
following to perform a specialized
experiment at LHC and namely this is
done after the completion of the lab
program and also the lab 200 program and
we intend to use much of the existing
l-3 detector and also
the existing infrastructure we have and
clearly we have to modify the detector
and this is based on the results we are
having then and we are doing at the
moment in this Rd efforts now when I say
we are planning to do this then this is
the existing l3 collaboration and here
just to give you the names of all the
Institute's involved and these are 38
institutes of 14 countries and also in
addition recently a lot of other groups
have expressed interest to continue this
work with l3 at LHC and so recently we
have in addition for this project 22
Institute's from seven countries which
are listed here which want to explore
also the PP collision with the modified
l3 detector okay so how can we modify l3
for proton collisions and this is in
fact how l3 looks like or will look like
at the time when the lab 200 program is
started so the change is then that we
will have also the forward muon system
which is indicated here so our plan then
is starting from this detector to at the
moment we are having two designs two
possible designs namely after the
completion of the lab program there will
be one year to modify the detectors and
to install new detectors and then
there's one possibility to go to a
specialized muon electron detector this
way which then in the first phase which
means the minimum modification of l3
will allow us to explore luminosities up
to 10 233 and then in the next step in
the second modification we will be able
to explore very high luminosity is the
highest luminosity that LHC of two times
ten to thirty four the other possibility
we are thinking of is to go to a muon
electron and photon detector this
requires some more modification in the
but then we will also be able right from
the start to really explore the highest
luminosities and then in the second
phase we will install a very precise
crystal calorimeter as a photon detector
and this will allow us especially to
explore this Higgs decay into two
photons and of course we will be able to
run at the highest luminosities okay so
let me first now go this line here
namely the specialized muon electron
detector and explain the plants we have
at the moment and this is now how this
detector would look like where we see
here the existing l3 detector in blue
the existing moon chambers and these are
the muon chambers for lab 200 then we
will add in the very forward direction
the magnetised iron to our art system
with proportional chambers here to
extend the coverage formula in the
forward direction then we will insert a
superconducting coil at this point which
provides a magnetic field of six Tesla
and we will replace the calorimeter
inside and also the inner tracker inside
to be able to run at very high
luminosities now in the other view this
detector looks as follows where you see
here this typical l3 structure with the
return your coil neuron system and then
here the superconducting coil
calorimeter
and inner tracker so let me explain a
little bit the idea behind this and
first the magnetics the field system
where now this superconducting coil
provides this field in the inner region
which is six Tesla the field returned in
the field return we also use this
forward tort system and then the field
returns through this McMurran chamber
volume and here we have a field of
something like point five Tesla inside
of this high magnetic field region
six Tesla we have then a new calorimeter
system which is shown here where you can
distinguish three parts the central part
indicated here which has an absorber of
tungsten with silicon readout in the
front and the gas readout in the back
with some copper plates then the forward
region here we have a couple absorber
with gas chamber readout and in the very
forward region in the endcap region
again because the particle density is
very high
we have tungsten with some gas readout
and also you can see here the new inner
tracker system indicated in red where we
have several layers of inner trackers
which are used in this high magnetic
field to measure the momentum of
particle with very high precision so the
total thickness of this new calorimeter
the instrumented thickness is six to
seven lambda and together with a
superconducting coil the total filtering
thickness is larger than nine lambda
everywhere here in this region now let
me explain a little more in detail the
inner tracker system as I already
mentioned there are several layers of
these new trackers and each layer
consists of straws namely five layers of
straws and each straw has a diameter of
four millimeters with a precision of
hundred twenty microns outside of the
calorimeter we have a somewhat larger
the tubes which have five millimeters
times ten millimeters cross-section and
here the precision is 160 micron and as
you see here from the expectation that
the occupancy per tube and per bunch is
of the order of a few percent in all all
of these layers
here just to indicate again how many
channels we need for this system where
for each tracker here it's indicated the
amount of electronic readout channels
you need to find tracks in the system
and in total we need something like
hundred thousand a little bit more than
hundred thousand read our channels and
also what's indicated here in the
forward region we have this multi wire
proportional chambers to find tracts in
a very forward region where the particle
density is very high now what is the
basic idea with this detector why do we
have this large magnetic field and this
can best be shown in this picture where
we see a high momentum ion 500 GeV
overlaid with twenty minimum bias events
and that is in fact what you would see
every 15 nanoseconds at LHC you would
have such a picture and you see already
with these all these events here it's
very difficult to isolate the real
interesting track but clearly a six
Tesla field helps a lot because all
these backgrounds have very low PT and
therefore they curl up in this large
magnetic field such that at this point
where you have your tracker for instance
here's a tracker layer here is another
one the particle density actually from
these background tracks is very small
and therefore this allows you to
identify this track of the muon track
very cleanly and this can be seen a
little bit more quantitatively in these
diagrams where we have the occupancy in
different trackers versus the magnetic
field for instance here is a tracker at
five point five meter radius point seven
point eight and one point three meter
radius and you see if you for instance
have zero magnetic field you have a very
high occupancy twenty percent but then
going down here with increasing magnetic
field you see at six Tesla you reduce
your Cuban Sofia quite a lot here is
seventy percent seventy centimeters and
you see the further you are
you have a very small occupancy and you
clearly can see the effect of the large
magnetic field so the immune system in
this design the muon detector the
present l3 muon detector provides very
good momentum resolution up to something
like 200 GV and also this moon detector
serves to identify miron's
and to find the track such that we can
trace back the track to the inner system
to the inner trackers and then the inner
tracker will provide a very good
momentum resolution especially for
tracks larger than 200 GV and here now
to summarize the resolution for muons I
have the resolution immune with a
momentum resolution as function of the
polar angle theta and you see that for
tracks below something like hundred GeV
the resolution is typically in the range
of 2% and even at very high momentum of
500 GeV the resolution stays around 5%
now if you take all the parameters of
this proposed detector including the
efficiency to identify electrons muons
and so on I have here a simulation for
Higgs events and we are talking here
about 150 GeV Higgs boson and the decay
of into the zeros is zero going to
electron on neuron together with all
possible backgrounds and also what's
included in this simulation are 80
minimum bias events overlaid with each
higgs event and clearly you see this
very clean Higgs peak in all these modes
of EE mu mu for muon and also for
electron and in each case the precision
let's say the mass resolution is of the
order of 1% in all these cases so
therefore clearly we will be able to see
the Hicks if it happens to be in that
mass range but also for instance if the
Higgs is very heavy 600 GeV for instance
again this is a simulation the same
decay mode with all background included
and in one year we would expect to see a
signal over 600 GeV Hicks of this type
and to just to show the momentum
resolution of this detector for muons
for instance here we have a Z Prime
extremely heavy of 40 evey decaying into
mu plus mu minus and that would be what
we would observe where you have here the
natural width and with the muon detector
we can reconstruct the Z prime with very
high precision and we obtain then a mass
resolution of 7% for such a 40 evey
object so now let me come to the next
line the next design we have at the
moment we are thinking about namely a
specialized muon electron and photon
detector and the design considerations
now are somewhat different because again
we have to build a detector which is
able to cope with this huge background
we have at LHC and now we keep a low
field a low magnetic field but then we
go to very large radius to reduce the
occupancy at the detector and also we
have a crystal calorimeter especially
for high-precision photon detection now
this detector then looks as follows
where you see again the l3 component
here the magnet the coil and also we
keep the outer immune chamber layer here
indicated in blue but then the
modifications we apply are as follows
that we move some neon chambers to the
outside to the outside of the magnet
system indicated here and also we insert
two layers of resistive plate chambers
which are used now to identify moons
outside of the iron and then they allow
us to trace back the moon to the inner
system where then with the inner tracker
system we are able to measure the
momentum of these mirrors and also we
were then
have a heaven calorimeter at very large
radius this crystal calorimeter and a
new inner tracker system now let me
start from the inside to explain this
detector here is the new tracker system
we will have in this detector where you
see layers of trackers at 140 centimeter
radius and 280 centimeter radius and
these trackers are built out of
proportional chambers and drift tubes
and also in the forward region where we
have proportional chambers between 22
and 40 degrees and gas microstrip
chambers in the very forward region and
the total thickness of this tracker is
smaller than 2% of x 0 so why do we need
these different technologies and this
can be seen here where in the barrel
region so this is theta so the barrel
region we see here the particle density
per unit area per second so in the
central tracker we have particle
densities up to 10 to the 5 and then
this density increases sharply in the
forward region such that here we can use
drift cubes and proportional chambers
here we use proportional chambers and in
the very forward region we use
microstrip gas chambers which have very
high can have a very high rate now this
system then has the following resolution
where we have here as function of theta
again the momentum resolution of this
tracker system and we see that 400 GeV
tracts the resolution is typically
around 3% from 10 to 90 degrees and even
at 500 GeV we still see that the
resolution is of the order of 12% or so
which then is used to for instance
measure the momentum of higher energy
moons
now let me come to this crystal
calorimeter which is shown here is like
a barrel which consists of crystals and
we will have one hundred thousand
crystals arranged in such a barrel
structure with the radius of three
meters now which crystal can we use and
wait since one candidate which is under
discussion at the moment is cerium
fluoride and to compare now serial and
fluoride with the BG or crystals we have
presently you see that the density is
slightly smaller six radiation lengths
is a little bit larger not much larger
but what is important now for LHC is the
fact that the decay time for this
crystal is much smaller it's only 20
nano second compared to 304 bgo and also
what is interesting that the temperature
dependence is very much smaller than BGO
which makes it much simpler to perform
precise calibrations so here just to
list a few properties of cerium fluoride
it has very good mechanical properties
it has an emission in a visible region I
said there is nearly no temperature
dependence and also it has a very good
radiation hardness so this is certainly
a very good candidate and the question
of course in crystal colorimeters is
always it was exactly the same with bgo
how do you get all these crystals you
need and clearly at the moment if you
would buy it you had to pay a huge
amount of money but we have these very
good connections to the Shanghai
Institute of ceramics because also the
bgo detector has been built there and
they are willing to produce such a
crystal of 50 cubic meter for 70 million
Swiss francs and already they have a lot
of the infrastructure available because
of the construction of the video
calorimeter and also one should note
that China is in fact the first producer
of cerium oxide
and other rare earth materials so
therefore it's clearly a very good
possibility for us to get all the
crystals we need and now just let me go
a little bit into detail where I just
point out a resolution we can obtain
with this detector and clearly the
resolution is the crucial point here
that's the reason why we go to crystal
kilometers and here this formula gives
you the resolution Sigma over E I don't
want to go into detail to explain all
this so this is just the intrinsic part
for cerium fluoride then there are other
important points which we have to
control namely for instance noise
pile-up and of course the calibration
now noise for instance you need to keep
the electronic noise low you need to go
to a low capacitance readout and that's
the reason why we prefer a low magnetic
field and therefore we can use photo
diodes which give fairly no low noise
and to control this pile-up problem we
go to large radius because the pileup
scaled like 1 over R squared and that's
the reason why we place these crystals
far away from the vertex and there's
actually another very good reason to go
to a large radius and this is seen here
the vertex uncertainty at LHC is
typically five point seven centimeters
and such if you are looking for the
Higgs go to photon you have a natural
uncertainty in the higgs mass because
you don't know we need of the vertex of
the event and therefore if you see this
here this uncertainty coming from the
vertex uncertainty in the higgs mass as
function of the detector radius you see
clearly this big improvement if you go
to a three meter radius compared to
let's say two a one meter radius and
clearly what we need to see the Higgs in
this mode we need something which is of
the order of 0.5 percent and that's the
reason why we place this detector at 3
meter radius now as I mentioned already
that we are really interested in this
Higgs goes to gamma gamma mode
and with this detector then with this
calorimeter we would observe in one year
the following signal where you see here
this really enormous background and this
signal here of the Higgs and clearly
from this you already see what you
really need is an extremely high
performance calorimeter if you have a
cal room table is poor resolution you
will really see nothing here and now
performing a background subtraction you
see these kind of Peaks for various
Hicks masses between 80 and 160 GeV and
in each case you have typically
something like twelve even 20 18 at very
low mass at something like seven Sigma's
and this corresponds to this kind of
integrated luminosity and this channel
is actually very important because if
the Higgs happens to be in that mass
range of 8230 let's say this will be the
only way to find it
all right so if the Higgs happens to be
heavier clearly this detector is also
able to explore these other decay modes
and again here we have nearly came out
in these zeros is 0 into electron muon
and again we have electron muon for
electron and form you on mode and also
with this detector the mass resolution
is of the order of 1% even for electrons
in this case slightly better but again
if the Higgs is heavier than this
for instance again the 600 GeV also with
this detector then we will clearly see
in one year a signal a signal signal for
the Higgs and of course here now this 6
is very broad and this is really
dominated by the natural width of this
600 GV exposing so in fact you see that
with this detector we will be able to
cover the complete mass range of the
Higgs from 90 GeV up to 600 and higher
and therefore I think even when I am 46
probably there's a very good chance that
we actually know where the Higgs McCann
is there or whether it's just some
mathematical trick but of course also we
will find something else if it's there
for instance the Z prime of four TV
again and now with the electron mode we
clearly can reconstruct the Z prime we
like with the natural width there you
see here this very good agreement with
the natural Whitaker so therefore to
conclude what we are planning is to
build a detector for LHC and the spirit
is really that we want to upgrade the
existing detector to use most of the
facilities we have and thus it upgrade
should be simple enough such that we can
implement it in a very short time it's
in one year or so so we are ready when
LHC is ready and also we were so we can
do this with moderate additional
resources and clearly the designs
emphasize running at the highest LHC
luminosities okay thank you
you